disturbing new signs at the grip of the
deadly coronavirus pandemic is
tightening in this country as more than
a dozen states see an uptick in kovat 19
cases the increase comes as the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention
issues new guidelines for states to
reopen the CDC projects another 26,000
deaths in the US over just the next
three weeks that would bring the total
to 140,000 by July 4th all of this is
new hot spots emerge in the south and
southwest Michael George begins our
coverage at the epicenter of the
country's outbreak in New York City
Michael good morning
Jeff good morning health experts say we
could be seeing the impact of reopening
too early the south and west coast of
the United States are now seeing their
biggest spike in coronavirus cases yet
in Houston there's a warning people
should not take take things lightly or
assume that the virus is under control
Texas businesses and restaurants among
the first to reopen could become the
first to shut down again the city of
Houston and Harris County and 267 deaths
I want the reopening to be successful
I want the economy to be resilient but
I'm growing increasingly concerned that
we may be approaching the precipice the
precipice of a disaster in Arizona more
than a thousand new cases per day up
from fewer than 400 a day in mid-may
when stay at home orders eased question
is you know did we be open to suing you
know is a valid one dr. franklin vecchio
is an emergency medicine doctor in the
Phoenix area he reports seeing a surge
of severe cases requiring intubation
yesterday North Carolina's governor
asked citizens of his state to help stop
the spread today is North Carolina's
highest day of new cases since the
pandemic started these numbers show the
disease is spreading and that more
people need hospital care and this has
to be taken seriously this week South
Carolina and Florida showed their
highest daily coronavirus cases yet
Arizona's average daily cases nearly
tripled in two weeks and this week Texas
had its four worst days so far four
hospitalizations Utah and Oregon are now
delaying their openings a week after
cases there continue to surge as I've
said zillion times the virus makes the
timelines we don't make the timelines
the CDC issued new guidelines Friday
including bringing your own food and
drinks to cookouts waving at people
instead of hugging sanitizing hands
after using an ATM and taking the stairs
instead of an elevator
and some encouraging signs here in New
York which at one point was the
epicenter of the outbreak the state now
says it has the lowest transmission rate
in the country
the governor credits the decision to
hold off on reopening Dana alright
Michael thank you